so humor above all requires the truth so
of course
most real comedy has been banned for the
last year it's one of the many
casualties of totalitarian liberalism
one of the few places you can still find
humor is a website called the babylon b
and here was their contribution
yesterday quote woman escapes the
patriarchy to find
freedom in grueling 80-hour work week
local business analyst abby stoughton
the piece begins
has finally escaped the shackles of the
patriarchy to find freedom and worth in
an 80-hour work week
working for an overbearing boss this is
true happiness said stone as she
sat through her fourth meeting of the
day discussing first quarter sales
figures for melcorp corporation
my feminist ancestors fought so i could
answer to 12 different middle managers
in a thankless
job before going home to an empty
apartment and drinking wine
i have reached the pinnacle of womanhood
yes the piece explains
staunton's job is awful and pointless
and sometimes she is sexually harassed
but quote at least she doesn't have to
live a boring life of
housemaking with a husband and kids i
don't want all that
domestic suburban bliss because that's
not feminist she said aloud
as she daydreamed about being barefoot
in the kitchen with a rich lumberjack
husband
now if you excuse me i have to redo the
cover sheets on these tps reports before
my boss threatens to fire me again
end quote now it's funny because
it's completely real the most important
thing young women can do with their
lives says sheryl sandberg and so many
other ceos
is work for a soulless public company
maximizing shareholder value
give us everything they promise and
you'll be
free it's weird how much modern feminism
has begun to sound like corporate
propaganda
talk about oppressing women